the finale of the Mandalorians inaugural
season proved to be a massive Pandora's
box of lore paving a way for all the
future conflict to define mandos return
in the second season let's take a look
at how much bigger man dos story has
become and what it will mean for the
next hotly anticipated season whenever
it arrives within the action-packed
shell of the mandalorian chapter 8 a
rich succulent nugget of
characterization from Ando was slowly
revealed his brush with death gave us
the first opportunity we've ever had to
actually see Pedro Pascal in his role as
the mandalorian when IG 11 removes his
helmet to save his life under the
amusingly convenient technicality that
the Droid isn't a living being which
means mando wouldn't wound his honor by
revealing his face to him so what
happens if you take that thing off they
come after you and kill you no you just
can't ever put it back on again it's a
deeply humanizing moment for our hero
whose full name has now been spoken on
screen to show his face in his most
desperate moment visibly frightened and
lost like any other person in the face
of death additionally it's particularly
special because IG 11 came to represent
a mirror for mando and the kind of man
he used to be after a little help
shaking off the grim reaper mando had
bestowed upon him an official signet to
represent his complete identity within
the Mandalorian Creed and finally got a
slick jetpack of his very own being of
no traditional Mandalorian clan himself
he has become his own collective unit
with the child aka baby Yoda as a clan
of two and was given his mission
returned the child to where it belongs
that said it's become painfully clear
that if the child belongs anywhere it's
with mando but again that's the
overarching emotional journey we're
going on with our favorite chrome domed
hero as he continues fully realizing
that underneath his Mandalorian armor
the character fans have fallen in love
with over the course of the series first
season is named din Jaron mandos
canonical names snuck out into the
public eye some weeks ago so you may
have already heard it if you were paying
attention but at the end of the day his
true moniker is
of any terrible consequence or meant to
be a forbidden secret the importance in
revealing is name now on the mandalorian
chapter 8 is both to underline just how
dangerous moth Gideon is and also to
compound the humanization of Manda's
character that occurs within the episode
nobody hanging out with him on screen
needs to call him by his name but we
should hear it in this particular
episode's context after we've learned
many of this man's deepest truths and
see him at his lowest moth Gideon likely
knows very little about mando as a
person and only knows his name because
it's on an official governmental list on
Mandalore
but moth and everything he represents
makes for the perfect kind of
prepackaged instant villain for our
helmeted hero you may think you have
some idea what your on possession of but
you do not moth is directly
representative of the Mandalorians
galactic genocide and the society that
robbed pre Mandalorian Dinge ahran of
his original family which we have
finally gotten the witness in its
totality and that's before we even get
to the threat the governor represents to
the child truly Mothe gideon is the
specter shadowing man those entire
existence as a person consistently
robbed of a permanent home and family
it's perfect narrative poetry this is
the thing in person from which mando
must defend his new tiny clan we'd say
he's doing a pretty good job of pulling
it off on the season 1 finale of the
Mandalorian moth Gideon emerges from his
wrecked TIE fighter and reveals the real
twist by holding the mythical dark saber
that sure was a last-second lower drop
wasn't it for those unfamiliar the dark
saber is an ancient lightsaber dating
back over a millennium the handmade
weapon of the first Mandalorian inducted
into the Jedi Order the dark saber was
stolen in the midst of the Old
Republic's low war ridden demise and
then returned to Mandalore it stayed
there for centuries to become a
generational token passed down to
descendants of the vizla clan that once
ruled the home planet very very long
story short when the Empire fell the
dark saber was in the possession of a
Mandalorian woman named VOC tin leader
of the pro Republic Mandalorian forces
however that's where the trail ends
just before the Battle of Yavin and the
official fall of the empire somewhere
between eight and ten years prior to
this episode of the Mandalorian VOC
attend obviously no longer possesses the
dark saber and we can only assume she
would give it up over her dead body
ominous huh it's a curious turn for the
Star Wars franchise to pass the lore
baton from an animated series back to a
live-action one in such a big way and on
to such an utterly blank page - this is
doubly true when you consider that
animated series like the Clone Wars and
rebels were primarily aimed at children
and the Mandalorian really isn't when
the Empire fell Mandalore was in a state
of civil war no further canonical
information exists so the Mandalorian is
gleefully seeking to fill those pages up
on its own terms this is no small side
story anymore the show will enter a new
phase in its second season as a
full-throated major piece of canon
thanks to the dark saber reveal if Bo
Catan is indeed dead and the dark saber
has been stolen from its people what's
the political state of Mandalore post
Empire the Republic led forces seem to
be on the ascent along with the rest of
the rebellion but the heart of the
conflict for the Mandalorians in the
past several canonical decades was
whether or not to become more pacifist
relinquish martial culture how much does
that matter to the plot of the
Mandalorian and how in blazes did an
Imperial remnant governor get a hold of
the MacGuffin that the dark saber
represents we'll be sitting on our hands
for the next several months waiting to
find out when the second season of the
Mandalorian arrives hopefully sometime
in 2020 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]